for this cake everybody i will pay i
will pay um yeah so stressful morning oh
no
getting in trouble
would you do it again was it that tasty
cake yeah i'll do it but do it clever
next time i play criminal cake i pay for
it yeah
the life of a chess player
yeah it's nice cake but you know
all right here we go game three magnus
eric and what are we seeing on the board
yeah it's a slow start to this game as
we saw eric arriving a bit late there
but it's transposed now into the queen's
gambit and a variation of the queen's
gambit declined that means that black
not taking one of the white pawns that
has been offered up early on and eric
going for a very solid variation uh will
we go into what we call the taresh
defense named after siegbert tarash very
very strong chess player from the past
or will we go into the semi-tarash
defense where we see different types of
porn trades look at all the pawns in the
central board right now there's options
for white magnus in the past has taken
one of those pawns he's also just can
maintain the tension and let eric make
that decision
to trade or not to trade that's the
question at this early stage magnus just
weighing up his options yeah i have to
say it does feel like it's a little bit
of a risky decision because i know
magnus is the world champion and he's
played everything but he's he really has
used this opening on the black side so
many times and i've never seen eric
use this opening have you nope uh eric
he's normally a specialist of the
grundfeld defense we discussed that a
bit earlier actually in the last game
between prague and duda but eric in the
grenfell defense lost to prague
yesterday lost to magnus today so he's
changed opening he's gone to something
that he nearly never uses maybe he plays
this opening more in blitz online or in
bullet chess but um it's not his normal
opening and okay we did see a trade of
pawns even a trade of knights and it's a
very similar pawn structure to what we
saw in the last game so it's very
grunfeld desk uh the type of position
looks like a grindfeld but it's a
different opening and in this type of
position white having the pawn center
normally gives a long-term advantage
white often actually trading the
advantage of the pawn center later for
an attack against the black king look at
black's king not many defenders around
it so
okay it's still early days this is still
a very well known position
there are even chessable courses on this
position i'm thinking by linear
dominguez one of the very strongest
american players now uh but yeah it's a
solid choice for black but if eric
doesn't know the ins and outs of it i'm
scared for him
yeah we do see a lot of our viewers
cheering on eric
in his match now against magnus another
move here yep just getting ready to
bring the black bishop out to a long
diagonal
very sensible both sides just developing
magnus will castle the white king now
so let's hear what eric said to savada
after
game two finished with a drool
eric you stand against quite the heart
attack there for a long time and you
deliver a good defensive game eventually
i i don't think i did but
somehow the position fizzled out into uh
well i mean i was just much worse
i was playing i don't know i was it's
weird right now i was sure i was going
to lose that game uh i think magnus must
have
made some inaccuracy i didn't see
exactly uh where but i was under
pressure and uh i'm just thinking right
now towards the end of the game i missed
a chance maybe to play h5
but the way i'm playing right now i'm
not surprised i missed uh i'm missing
i'm missing so many moves in these games
but um
yeah just one of those situations where
i was in a bad position so i decided you
know what better better play upon down
and be active than suffer
in a
by holding holding my materials so that
strategy paid off but i don't think it
was because i played particularly well
so i definitely can't allow magnus
such favorable
positions in the next game
we had a tweet coming in here from
someone who watched your interview
earlier today who said it was hard to
hear this interview from eric henson i
love magnus carlson but keep your head
up eric bounce back strong canada is
proud
yeah i mean i appreciate the
the words of encouragement
um but there's something
very off with uh
my head right now i'm i'm missing so
much and uh yeah i think this game i was
pretty lucky to come out with a draw
good luck to you thank you
yeah eric not feeling his uh best today
and then game three here the bar has now
gone slightly over to magnus's side what
do you think now david yeah i'm not
looking too much of the bar yet but as
simon and i were actually just
discussing during the interview it's a
bit of an odd opening choice normally
white is the one pressing for the
advantage black you just want to trade
pieces off you want to survive to the
end game and you want to maybe just lock
things up maybe even go for the draw so
eric if he's playing for the draw in
this game even if he gets it we'll need
to strike back in the final game of the
day
yeah and uh yeah once again you know it
was quite hard again to hear eric so low
yeah and
yeah i i just
but one of the stories that kind of
motivated me um and brought me to tears
actually was i think from i can't
remember the year but it was a to do
with a canadian ski um speed skater dan
janssen and you know the first time he
played the olympic well he played he
skated in the olympics um he was 16
years old he came forth and everyone was
like wow what an amazing talent and then
of course the olympics is every four
years so he had to wait for another four
years to have a chance he was by then
like super fast and he kept messing up
you know you know his sister died and he
had to race raced her uh the day after
the his her death and it just kept
messing up there was something not
working for him and it was his final
shot
at the olympics and he was like 32 years
old
and you know he's already made a mess of
the first event which is his favorite
and
he comes to the last event that he's
skating in and he's like okay i have no
shots at this
let me just sit back and smile let me
think about the journey that skating has
taken me all the amazing people that
i've met let me just relax
and enjoy this and i'm going to skate
for them
and he broke the world record yeah he
won it was a
incredible story
so yeah eric has to take inspiration
from that and
uh he mentioned actually in that
interview he was in big trouble in the
last game he was lucky to make a draw
and sometimes that's when the momentum
changes in a match when you do make a
lucky escape suddenly no more pressure
nobody expects him to win this game so
maybe that's when the best things happen
and uh meanwhile a few moves on the
board simon do you
uh kind of are you revising your opinion
of black's opening just as we're about
to see a big pawn sacrifice actually
uh big night not at all i mean the this
move that magnus has played is is is the
idea and the position it was first
played um i think by pogoleski
and i've probably said that really badly
but it was played
that's the one yeah and i actually met
him once he's a well-known theoretician
i think it was him against tau who
played this idea first even going back
to like the 70s 80s it's a well-known
idea
and the idea is to sacrifice pawn but
start
a very dangerous kingside attack and i
think this is all theory i've seen harry
move up in that position and i would not
be surprised if this has uh just you
know been seen before and we can have a
look at it on the analysis board and
the point is the pawn's taken and
david's showing that white's idea is
then to push the white pawn forwards
attacking that knight and you have to
move that knight now if the knight
retreats which is one obvious idea
you're very passive and this pawn
sacrifice gives white this open bishop
look at the bishop pointing towards
black's king and you can even bring more
pieces around by now moving the knight
and we talked about the square a lot uh
the f5 square i can't remember the
saying now f5 it will thrive i think
and then you've got three pieces
attacking a lone king so this kind of
this kind of position is extremely
dangerous with the pawn so i expect if
we go back a little bit eric won't want
to go passive for that night but when
it's attacked by the pawn he will try to
block the bishop and come forwards
into this square at least this way you
block out one of your opponents
attacking pieces still very dangerous
though white could go for that same
night maneuver or he could even bring a
rook to the center and threaten to
capture the night there's many ideas and
this has all been seen before this is
one of the reasons i don't like this
opening for black i know lots of strong
players play it but it's so tricky to
defend this attack and let's see what
happens i'm sure now the night comes
forwards as as we said and then and
magnus knows exactly what he what he's
doing the knight is heading towards the
black king um magnus on the attack um
critical moment
yeah and they always say that when a
knight reaches the f5 square it's worth
at least a pawn so it's such a great
attacking piece and i agree with you
simon this is very very dangerous and
magnus clearly knows his classics i mean
i don't know whether this has been
played in this exact move order but the
idea that's so important yeah it's all
about the idea and recognizing patterns
i mean that game you mentioned there um
simon that polygamy game was actually a
really nice sacrifice in it uh within it
magnus we've seen his memory it's
phenomenal he knows that game inside out
he knows countless other games that have
arisen in this position or at least this
type of position and eric we mentioned
it's not his main opening so that's the
battle that eric faces right now he's
facing a very confident magnus carson
and magnus carlsen who's analyzed lots
of little kind of ideas in this type of
position and
it's not easy it feels like an uphill
battle already black one pawn up but
about to come under a big attack do you
know what i need sorry i was just going
to say do you know what we need to do
tomorrow well i need to bring eric some
cake yes maybe not
maybe he would like stolen cake
i i would never do that intentionally it
was an accident
it's quite scary when the alarms go off
and you're like oh yeah you know like i
believe the alarms went off that's
because of
a cake
i know and uh but let's bring eric some
cake tomorrow yeah i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna get this lovely coconut cake oh
yeah i love it i'm going to bring it to
eric tomorrow yes and did you do it and
if you're wondering what kind of cake
this is it's actually called a
schoolabola in norwegian ah yes it's
very tasty
yeah translated
it's very it's very good yeah that's one
of my favorites as well yeah we'll have
stealing yeah
don't ever do that i didn't say that
don't do that and just a quick reminder
to everyone there is still very much
time to enter our competition to win the
air things view plus and you can do that
by answering our quiz question where
we're asking you who are you rooting for
in the oslo esports cup and very
importantly why
and
it's lovely to see your tweets and your
answers and
that well you can tweet your answers
using the hashtag chesschamps great for
the players to get your energy as well a
lot of you rooting for magnus carlsen of
course if he wins as much today and
pragnanda loses he is down by two points
against judah remember
then they will be tied on points heading
into the last day but magnus he has uh
he did win that match against prague so
in direct encounters magnus will be on
top of the table actually and also duda
will be only one point behind it's going
to be a dramatic final day in the
tournament
he had a move yeah
we do see a defensive move from eric you
know he's retreated the bishop just to
cover the all-important f5 square
yeah so we have to show this it looks
really ugly really counter-intuitive
retreating the bishop back to its
starting square back to where it came
from just about five moves ago but as
ivanka mentioned there's only one idea
in the position
by this move and it's to cover this
dream square so if the white knight
jumps forward now getting ready to
attack the black king then it will be
immediately removed and traded off by
the black bishop and a trade here
actually helps black a lot suddenly
white loses that key attacking piece of
the night and actually you can even gain
time against the white queen now black's
king much safer once the knight has left
the board so ugly move but necessary
maybe simon
yeah i mean it's a very hard move to
bring yourself to play because
i mean you don't want to move your
pieces backwards i mean who who on earth
wants to do that and
magnus has a couple of natural moves the
most natural he's only got one piece
which is not doing anything just look at
the pieces and that's the rook next to
the king david highlighting and if we
just have a look where that rook can
move always look at the pieces which are
not doing anything and you can move that
two squares into the middle and this
actually creates uh some nasty threats i
feel um of capturing the knight next
move and when black recaptures you can
see you're clearing up the rook towards
the queen and there may well be a night
jump here i mean i i can't see anything
completely crushing but something like
davis put on the board look at those
beautiful rooks so that to me looks like
a very sensible move but you've even got
ideas like bringing the other rook right
down into the position um that could be
a very funky move if we go back um and
just maybe i'm more i'm obviously
looking at losing my rook over there
which is kind of ridiculous but you
always want to sacrifice simon i know
even in good positions i've got to stop
it but it's got to stop it but in this
position there are triggers there are
kind of signals which show that you can
get away with sacrifices because look at
the king no defenders around it and
simon this is oh sorry simon you
mentioned a few days ago
it's all about this pawn as well any
time as white you get a pawn to this
square it signals an attack in this
direction against the black king somehow
this pawn just takes away defensive
squares that black wants to use for
example the black knight wants to go
back and defend but can't use it because
of this pawn
anytime as white you get a pawn like
this if you have major pieces on the
board queens rooks knights etc then go
for an attack against the enemy king
that is the signal
so yeah nice move there i'm expecting
one of those two simon as you mentioned
this one may be the most natural because
it's not doing anything this piece and
we know magnus loves to bring every
piece to the party but uh this one also
looking good i suppose sorry david i've
just seen one other move as well i mean
you could move has he gone in with the
rook he looks like this okay wow i
predicted it simon wow for once i got it
right so i don't think he's going to
take the pawn near black's king though i
think that's not yet not yet maybe later
yeah maybe later yeah he's cleared
another square for his rook actually the
two rooks might team up on this line as
well looking very good
if eric were to ask the question
what are you going to do with the rook
on the sixth row and just uh attack it
with the bishop yeah
and is this waving at a red flag and
saying come on i think magnus's idea is
to get rid of the black knight as you
mentioned there's no safe squares
actually for the white rook on this
fight on this line you could make an
argument for taking this pawn but it
feels premature to attack at the moment
uh so you need to get rid of black's
best defender first the knight so trade
it off um you can't actually take the
white rook now with your bishop because
white's knight recaptures attacking the
black queen gaining time that's very
important white would have two pieces
now a bishop and a knight for just a
rook
so black instead would have to capture
the white bishop and now the white rook
will just sidestep one square and look
at this strength uh of the white rook
right now and we're going to see this
actually happen in the position just
looking at eric's screen on the right
top right corner there he's about to
move his bishop to this square so we
might see this position and white knight
on a dominant outpost in the middle look
how dark squared domination has occurred
while black only has a light-squared
bishop
it's looking very good actually i'm
surprised the evaluation bar says 0.0
because
i would be terrified as black yeah well
this is the difference between engines
and
humans as be for frank you know humans
have that psychological
fear and you know maybe the engine
some way down the line can spot some
kind of nifty resource that the human
just wouldn't okay and eric is asking
the question to magnus and
our guru david has predicted the right
move bishop takes knight on the board
process of elimination but it's very
logical as well yeah i mean there's also
the nice trick if you take the rook
maybe we could just show this as well
there's one one more variation uh okay
um we can maybe quickly show it yeah if
you do take the rook in that position uh
the knight takes okay at the moment um
it might seem okay black because black
can move the queen one square forwards
and you're attacking two minor pieces
but this is where pattern recognition
comes in and why you should practice
your tactics because there's a very nice
move here the bishop can simply take the
pawn this doesn't seem possible because
a queen takes bishop but then we see
these patterns working the knight now is
able to do what we call a fork winning
the queen so there's little patterns and
that's where you practice your tactics
they become second nature after all it's
a game of patterns you get used to them
you improve your tactics yeah and a
couple of moves but both sides just
improving their rooks and uh still the
status quo remains white has a very
strong rook here very strong knight very
strong queen it's just about whether
black can fight against them i wouldn't
be surprised at some point if we see
magnus kind of lift this rook into the
attack against the black king as well
every piece heading in that direction uh
it looks very very scary still for black
the bishop not being able to fight on
the dark squares
so yeah magnus trying to work out a way
to attack yeah and uh whilst magnus is
figuring figuring that out um well
earlier
you both mentioned polygamsky a famous
player from the past and i'd like to ask
you a question from elite mines who says
who is the best classical chess player
of all time it's your in your opinion
classical chess player yeah okay we have
sorry okay yeah i mean i'll let david go
first i mean with that one because
there's so many the so i mean the best
or the one we prefer the best it's quite
well it's up to you you can uh
maybe as well does that question mean
the best chess player in classical chess
or does it mean with a classical style
classical chess classical dress
i mean i i would say al alikin or
alakine um i was one of my favorites
because he he sort of revolutionized the
game when he came along before before
him
there were less rules and he he
basically was a great attacker but
unlike morphe who was before him morphy
attacked really like a complete nutter
basically you know his attacks were
really unsound but they were dangerous
uh alakine basically always nearly
always attacked after he got a position
of strength so he sort of uh
developed chess a lot um but i don't
know david what about who who would you
say i mean first of all that's really i
mean that's a really good point simon
for example this type of position where
magnus he's built everything up slowly
that's when alakine would start
attacking you don't just attack out of
nowhere you attack when you have nice
centralized pieces like white does right
now um so alakine good answer i'll just
say kasparov because i grew up
when he was dominant and he was so
dominant for so long um i think he won
what was it six world championship
matches five six world match uh
championship matches and
in style as well
my answer would be the same as well
i was kind of thinking like older people
i mean casper i mean like yeah i mean
you know classical i think you know the
old people
but yeah i mean kasparov great answer i
mean my favorite though is mikhail tao
without shadow of doubt i mean he he was
the uh he was just a lunatic completely
lunatic
and he was a one-of-a-kind uh absolute
uh what you never had anyone like him or
had he in the futural past that's
similar to him yeah i mean we're lucky
simon right being chess players and you
mentioned you just did course on the
cartel just i mean
it doesn't even sound like work it
sounds like fun going through his games
and playing through them and recording a
15 hour video course on chessable just a
day's work in my life yeah we remember
that everyone simon does have that
tall what is the name of the course
again it's uh life and times of mikhail
tao yep on chesable with 15 hour videos
that you can study to play like the
entertaining tal
and magnus an entertaining player
himself
if he wins this game he will win the
match
is that possible it's possible i must
say i like eric's last move i thought
black couldn't even get one piece active
but black now with his rook occupying
the third rank and he's actually stopped
that idea i mentioned earlier of white's
rook kind of using the third rank to
swing across and go for the black king
and okay i also like magnus's move this
is what we call prophylaxis in chess
it's where you know that checks are
coming later so you get ready for them
you get out of the way in advance you
know what your opponent wants to do
later
the king just sitting on the edge of the
board nice and safe actually evacuating
the first rank where it had no
protection so
magnus knows there's no way to break
through yet he's just improving every
single piece to the maximum first and we
did see eric shake his head a little
earlier his clock is ticking down we
know he's not feeling
confident today eric
you think magnus is sensing that and
playing some moves
yeah
you know that's psychology definitely
you know these top players there's no
disguising it they are predators when
they sense weakness they go in for the
kill this is all the mark about being
one of the belt's best uh
chess players and um chess is after all
essentially a battle game
it's a war bit of strategy and uh magnus
doing great things you know taking care
of his king he's posted his pieces on
aggressive squares and now it's up to
eric to come up with a response and uh
eric now has to make a choice on how
he's going to defend will he cope with
his pressure will he try to resolve the
difficulties in his position with active
means
it's up to eric now
yeah it's really up to eric and he
doesn't have that much time with which
to actually
come up with anything uh too fun too
creative too energetic with his position
i mean i'm looking at uh that kind of
strategy we discussed earlier how to
improve your worst place piece and if
you talk to eric's pieces the black
pieces actually the black rook on the
third rank down in white's camp very
nicely placed black's queen a bit
passive but stuck there black's bishop
same also a bit stuck you have to
improve the black rook next to the black
king and there we go he stole the words
right out of my mouth he did improve
that rook and you could maybe make an
argument for bringing the rook all the
way across teaming up the two black
rocks together but this one is maybe
even more solid we talked about the
white pawn the very strong white pawn in
the center of the board eric just
keeping an eye on that one so uh yeah
defending very very well eric over the
last few moves he just has to be careful
of the clock situation
down on time when you're defending it's
not an easy situation to be in yeah he
needs to draw eric hansen to take this
to a game four we could have a super
short day if magnus wins this game and i
did see the bars in a bunch of the other
games
going to the side of the player who with
a win will end the match in this round
three of games pragnanda of course we
are super interested in
he has to win this game but the bar is
over to do that side and with only a
draw duda will end that match and take
all three points is prague struggling in
that game um it's a wild one i'm just
looking over at prague's game and trying
to work out what's going on because it's
chaos on the board it looks like duda
sacrificed a piece temporarily but
we'll win it back with interest so uh
yeah it does look like duda is in
control but prague he's doing the right
thing he's taking risks he needs to win
and he's trying his best
and anish geary he is also in a must-win
situation losing two games with some mao
slipping today liam let the bar all the
way over to his side and with uh only a
draw or a win liam leia will take all
three points in that match is liam
winning it's looking very good uh it's
also the type of position where liam can
maybe just shut things down and get a
draw if he wants so
liam in control of that match and you
wouldn't he is up by one point against
mamadiara in that match
the bar may be more to the middle in
that one
is it possible to say if anyone is in
charge in the balance right now very
equal
all right and with a draw they will play
a game four but in each gear he is
definitely struggling against liam we
did hear in that interview talking about
clicking or dragging the pieces is that
actually a dilemma yeah it definitely is
and uh regular viewers of the show will
know that sometimes i say oh no me and
my arrows yeah and actually i've had the
same problem the exact same exact
problem as a niche sometimes i click on
a square when for example we have the
analysis board when i'm highlighting a
square
but then i'll drag to show the arrows
and the mixture between clicking and
dragging it doesn't sound like it should
affect things too much but the computer
has memory so if it's remembered you've
already clicked on a piece or clicked on
a square before and then you click on a
new piece sometimes it makes the move
for you so it can be tricky i guess it's
just practice practice practice and
anish he's played these events before so
it's surprising that it's happened now
but it does happen it's understandable
it does happen one and also another kind
of scenario where mouse slipped happen
is when you've kind of picked up a piece
you're ready to move it and then you
realize actually you don't want to move
that piece to that square so often it's
what you should do is you should
actually take that piece and move it in
a kind of unnatural ways and drop it off
the board
and then it will go back to its original
square
and
i would say there's so many new skills
aren't there online chess because i
remember when you played traditional
chess it was literally like the only
thing you can think it's very
interesting to see how people move right
in when they're playing with a board
because you get people slamming the
pieces down slammers you get screwers
they screw the piece into the ball come
to the board you get like the elegant
ones you look the other way you know
they do this so they're like with their
little finger up you know maybe a little
glass of champagne
so it's really weird but here you've got
the clicking you've got the dragon it's
a new thing but yeah we have some more
moves and and
i kind of like magnus's night maneuver
there dave but is it i
yeah i agree simon it's uh really
creative i don't think i would have come
up with this one because white's night
looked so glorious in the middle of the
board just a couple of moves ago but
maybe we can catch up with the viewers
on what's happened and simon you say you
like this i do too i must admit um so if
we just rewind a couple of moves we left
it here and white's knight as i
mentioned looks great in the center but
everywhere wants to jump forward too um
anywhere along these lines gets captured
by this black bishop the black bishop
actually dominates the white knight
right now so magnus looked for new
avenues of attack he dropped his knight
back gaining a bit of time against the
black rook and after the black retreated
challenging this guy then the white
knight rerouted itself so a trade now if
it does happen would very much favor
white because this knight actually
guards the white rook the black queen
cannot take it so the black queen has to
run away and if we see the queen retreat
for example just a trade of rooks very
simple trade of rooks and white's knight
coming in queen and knight i think will
be better than this queen of bishop
especially because white has this really
really strong pawn in the center right
now so i think that would be a mistake
by eric if he gets too nervous too hasty
and captures the white rook i think he
needs to take a timeout and maybe with
that variation in mind step out of the
way first with the black queen and uh
now this idea of trading rooks maybe
comes with a bit more power so maybe
magnus now would be forced to retreat or
forced to at least trade on black's
terms but
complicated position and uh eric he's
definitely the one on the back foot
despite what the evaluation bar says is
still white
who is trying to be creative and that's
kind of reflected in the clock times you
know magnus just under eight minutes
whilst eric
coming close to the three-minute mark um
one thing i have had experience in this
type of position is that if white's uh
attack backfires
then those passes on the
left hand side they can be very strong
and
well
okay eric not following your advice he's
actually traded rooks yeah i don't like
this the change in pawn structure we
mentioned white's pawn being really
strong earlier it's even stronger now
and actually maybe this is uh even
better than what i suggested keeping the
rooks on the board this second pair of
rooks for magnus
because now this white rook is actually
going to go up to the seventh rank
seventh heaven as we call it where all
of the black pawns lie all of the
targets are white's rocket pick takes
the time now to get to that c7 square
i think eric's in big big trouble yeah
this rook move that you suggested
driving the rook down to the seventh row
is so powerful and it's the best row for
rook
and of course let's not forget that
white's other pieces are ready to spring
in the action as well you know there's a
fantastic pawn two squares away from
queening um nicknamed delroy by jonathan
rousen he who wrote the seven deadly
chess scenes and also a white knight
planning to spring into the f5 square uh
it looks it looks starting to look bad
now but it was critical eric on his
screen he brought his rook forward he
kind of changed his mind brought it back
but then he did make that move
it looks desperate to me it looks like
he's trying to go for white central pawn
uh white's past pawn in the middle of
there but the black pieces are kind of
jumbled up and also it's allowed the
white knight to jump in
oh simon we mentioned this night i mean
you mentioned the night getting there
eventually it finally has made its
journey here is that a signal that a big
attack is incoming
yeah i mean i i think when you pick this
opening with the black pieces you kind
of got to expect what happened to happen
and then you've got to defend so
precisely
i mean it's not terminal yet by any
means because that pawn is blockaded and
you know i could have some
counter-attack at some point but i i am
with you guys that the white pawn is so
strong the white knight looks good
i don't know if magnus needed to play
that move straight away but with the
rook coming down just everything seems
to indicate that magnus has a very
comfortable advantage the clock time as
well it's just another indication that
this is going to be a tough tough game
for eric to to uh
to get something out of i think we've
really got to applaud eric if he saves
this game one and a half minutes left
now in a difficult position where
there's a fine margin i think yes the
evaluation bar says only 0.6 but if eric
makes one slip he's going to go right
off in white's favor so um yeah
dangerous times for eric i'm expecting
him to move the black queen you could
maybe move the black across one square
to attack the white knight then white
tonight might jump in with a check um
we'll see what happens but either way
one minute now for eric i know and i
have to say i just took a look at the
computer suggestions on my laptop and
i'm like
they
one of them is normal the other two the
other two are just crazy
actually diving forward with the queen
and that looks natural i mean look at
look at this porn move yeah and eric
doesn't play any of the top three
computer suggestions here we still see
them on our screen and uh the top
computer move as ivanka says crazy
nobody in the right mind will ever play
this if black had pushed his pawn in
front of his king we would have had to
kind of uh check the metro detector out
and check eric because this is so
unnatural opening up the black king when
you're about to get attacked anyway um
the other moves more natural maybe
bringing the rook across attacking the
white knight and queen this would have
allowed white's knight to jump in with a
check but uh eric instead uh of finding
maybe the third choice computer move
bringing his king to the center he's
brought his king to the corner very
human but maybe flawed and the white
knight jumping in now the reason the
king maybe isn't so comfortable in the
corner is because it no longer protects
this pawn which it would have done if
the king was more centralized
how do you defend it now it's not so
easy the black rook can step across one
square for example but the white queen
when she moves i'm not even sure okay
this has happened i'm not sure sure of
the best square here or here but no
matter where she goes
it just looks terrible for black now
this queen is completely stuck black is
essentially playing with a passive queen
passive bishop
i mean i i think this game sort of shows
you that um you know
eric hasn't you know defended 100 well
so far but it shows you how important
openings are at this level uh and again
um his opening is played a lot by top
players i still don't understand
entirely why um to be honest because it
gives you a tough position the computers
say it's okay but it's tough to play and
we have a big result you guys
it's a draw in game three with duda and
pragnanda and that means prague loses
the match
duda taking all three points and if
magnus now wins this match he will be on
the same point as pragnanda before the
final day
and magnus he did win the match between
them and will be in the lead so this is
great news for magnus carlson duda also
with three points will now be on 11
points he's only going to be
one point behind magnus and prague
before the final day and the bar shoots
up for minus yep and we're not that
surprised i think here in the studio
because the trend has been in white's
favor and
eric running out of ideas the black
queen is stuck as we mentioned the black
bishop stark black's rook can't really
improve itself
oh nice
such a classy move sadistic before we
get to that move uh black's pawns just
weakened themselves that's why the
evaluation bar shot up in white's favor
but
i'm not as optimistic about that move as
you guys uh white's king stepping back
to defend some pawns because i don't
think the king's that well placed here
but either way yeah magnus just showing
that he has the time he's just playing
with his food before he eats it i think
he's just dangling it around and just
thinking don't play with your food
though magnus it can go wrong he's just
playing on the clock as well he's just
trying to play kind of nothing moves to
make eric a bit nervous yeah i it must
have been because it was so unexpected i
was expecting all these forward moves go
forward with your rook go forward with
the queen uh instead
played with a flourish like
like like you suggested maybe with some
champagne as well little finger up yeah
there we see the arbiter trying to help
out jordan maybe some uh tech issues
there uh maybe something going on
six seconds for eric he needs to make a
move okay he retreats his bishop allow
the
yeah yeah it has to allow the rook in i
mean that rook coming in is this is the
top of the board white's rook now um
that's one of many moves white's rook
has options it can go up the board you
can go across the board to threaten
check
what is magnus gonna choose that black
bishop move i mean everyone groaned when
they saw that right eric himself
internally would have been groaning
that's not where he wants to put the
bishop but there was nowhere nowhere
else on the board i mean i really hope
eric it looks like he probably will lose
this game he's not too upset i think we
all do after this game because he's such
a fantastic player and he's so talented
and it's just from my eyes at least some
of his openings that he's sort of
letting him down and
that's because he he's a streamer he
doesn't work as much on his openings as
the other players so i really hope he
takes some confidence away and works on
his openings and comes back comes back
stronger um
i mean i don't know this this is there
any hope here i i mean what can white do
you've mentioned those rook moves dave
maybe we can have a look at one of them
and just see see how you think it could
go and magnus was looking towards the
top of his screen there so this is the
move maybe we're expecting going towards
the top of the board magnus just taking
a time out he's got a lot of time
so bringing the rook up this looks very
very strong hitting the black queen
hitting the black bishop behind it and
maybe indirectly the king
so this move remember the rook is
defended by white's knight this move
would force black to maybe give up a
piece sorry david i i did just cheat
there i don't often to look at the
computer and there's an amazing idea
that seems to win
rook instead of going that way it's the
other move you suggested david it's
threatening checkmate so let's show this
we go here and after you there's only
one sensible way to block this checkmate
you have to block it with your pawn
because the queen is threatening to come
in and now rook takes pawn wow there's a
killer tactic here and uh that's that's
why i have to say i cheated because i
wasn't going to see this one
phenomenal idea will magnus see this
idea if he does it oh
it's on the board look at his camera
look at magnus's camera he was about to
play it okay well black finds another
move after i said it's the only move
just to explain as well simon why we
think it's so genius the queen would
have come across here white sacrifices a
rook but no matter where you go with the
king now uh literally any square you
move the king to it's checkmate on the
next turn uh from the queen so uh okay
eric spotted that i think but in this
position instead of blocking with the
pawn he brought his rook across and now
plenty of moves should win but um the
most obvious one is yeah he's played it
okay bring his knight back but yeah he's
brought his knight back to f5 hitting
this pawn
overwhelming the square and remember if
the knight is captured it's checkmate
we're about to see the game over
um it looks like eric last stand eight
seconds seven seconds i'm expecting him
to perhaps make a one move by maybe push
the pawn forward and he has
so
magnus still has to
continue
that knight can go back where it came
from maybe
and it goes back
um oh but now maybe this queen takes
pawn yeah if the black queen takes the
white pawn in the center of the board
the white knight will retreat to the
center and the black rook is falling the
black rook is pinned the black can't
move because of the white queen and
this game is at any moment curtains
beautiful game for magnus as well i mean
i i think he
you don't even need to take the rook
immediately here you can you can
increase the pressure on that rook don't
rush into your decisions when you're
playing them uh but yeah magnus has
played very well in this game yeah
absolutely model game yeah eric just up
against the world champion in his best
shape and white's rook now we're
expecting it to slide across one square
to overwhelm the black rook black's rook
is defended twice right now but it can
be attacked by a third white piece uh
you pin and you win that's what uh i
always repeat that's the phrase that
we're told when we're young and here
that is the case black's rook has pinned
and it will drop off the board i have to
say um just looking at the scores as
well um if when magnus wins this game
there's only one
encounter left and that's found four
east versus mamojarov and if van forest
wins that one it's going to be an early
day
and it was looking good last time i
checked he's uh got an endgame advantage
van forest so we'll keep you guys
updated on that game absolutely i mean
that would be
insane that we had so many decisive
games that all three matches finished
after three rapid games what is that is
so the mix of players just entertaining
chess also be a question of stamina
who has the most energy for these
closing rounds you know my friend always
tells me he says jovi is not how you
start it's how you finish that's the
most important thing especially in a
tournament and uh here we're starting to
see who has the energy who has the
motivation who who is still
maybe better prepared and uh well we're
still waiting for magnus to show
well just to make the move the rook move
why are you not actually the more i
looked at it and same for magnus he
stopped for a long time here i thought
white was about to make a move and black
resigns but eric i think has got a
sneaky idea in mind and there we go
magnus doesn't play the move we thought
doesn't put pressure on the black brook
and we have to jump in because this game
might still go for a little while
here i thought the white rook slider
cross we mentioned this pin the black
rook is
indefensible but the black bishop could
suddenly leap out pinning itself
pinning this white knight suddenly and
after a few trades we see that actually
black might escape into the end game we
might have seen this where okay white
should be winning uh this pawn
eventually this is a winning end game
but a lot of hard work to be done so
magnus didn't go for that he's going for
the slow approach defending his night
now and after this pawn push he's trying
to win this blackrook with his own pawn
and uh this is even more sadistic than
the other idea that we showed uh eric
has to block the pawn advance but magnus
now can win at will this pin is never
disappearing he will win the blackrook
at his leisure what a move
that was by by magnus as well i mean uh
he's calculated that yeah he's just
three seconds two seconds one second
eric has to make the move did he make a
move has he moved in time eric it's
tight
he's lost on time it looks like oh no
worse kind of ending to the day for eric
hanson another win for magnus carlsen he
decides the match three points for
magnus carlsen that means he's in lead
in the oslo eastwards cup a loss for
eric hanson who just runs off what
happened in the end there i mean the
position is bad it's almost hopeless
anyway but eric just couldn't find a
logical move